let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
well happy afternoon
thanks for joining us today on let's
talk the tony michaels
it's three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern you know what time that is
we have a special guest with us today
today is a special guest
episode
i'm so happy to have her
with us we've been trying to get her for
a couple weeks
we have her we have her now on the show
today
now we're recording you guys know how
this works we record our guest episodes
and then we air them on friday so as
you're listening today is friday three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern and
you know you can go over to youtube you
can watch it on twitter you can watch it
on twitch when it's all said done you
can even listen to it
you can even listen to it but today i
have a beautiful face with me today so
maybe you'll want to watch it on the
ub2s the tubes of you
or on the twitty tweets or the twitch
but you can also download it on apple
spotify all your favorite directories
out there
and you're definitely going to want to
download this episode because today
we have someone that i've known for a
while from the tiki talk
uh she she does a lot of tick tock
videos she's also and i think we're
probably going to talk about this today
she's also been um i don't know what it
is over on instagram because i know i
say retweet but she's been shared i
don't know what you call it over there
maybe it's grammed i don't know i have
no idea i'm not on the insta's
maybe she'll clue us in to what that
what the proper
the proper uh
the word is for the retweeting
of the instigrams
so but but i'll tell you she has
she has appeared several times on mr d l
hugoley's instagram page which is which
is where we have this connection that
maybe she does or doesn't know or people
out there do or don't know
we were kind of in the same video kinda
on the l hugely's page
and i'll i'll get to that in a minute
but i want to introduce her versus nikki
new from tiktok
she's the host of the nikki new show
she's also on instagram
nikkinew813 if you just go type that
into the socials you'll find her it's
n-i-k-k-i-n-o-o-813
on instagram
twitter the tiki talks now she did have
her account banned and i'm sure
i'm sure she'll definitely talk about
her inst or her tick tock account that
had over six hundred thousand followers
that was permaban so but let's bring
nikki on
hey nicky how are you good tony thanks
for so much for having me on hey i i'm
happy you're here and i'm glad we
finally were able to get together to
record this episode because i'm so happy
for for my audience to get to hear uh
from another tick tocker as you know
i've had several tick tockers on my show
uh michael j has been on my show and a
few and a few others
but that's kind of where we have this uh
connection me and you i don't know if
you know this or not but when when you
posted a video of a duet with michael j
one black man's opinion over on tick
tock it ended up on dl hugley's
uh page and then it was it was
500 000 views on his page that's right
it was a huge viral video on his page
and then it seeped over to twitter
that's how i knew about it i'm like wait
a second
i am an easter egg on a dl hugely viral
video with nicki new in one black man's
opinion
and i i'll tell you why let me show the
video and maybe everyone will understand
well good morning us senate
feeling proud of ourselves are we
we made juneteenth a federal holiday to
which i say who gives a [ __ ]
we didn't ask you for that [ __ ]
there's an anti-lynching bill where the
[ __ ] is that
there's an anti-black hate bill where
the [ __ ] is that
republicans are actively
trying to stop the black boat in several
states including texas
but juneteenth
is a federal holiday this ladies and
gentlemen is placation
once again black america is being given
some [ __ ] to go could you just be
quiet could you just go away no [ __ ]
[Music]
been there done that got the t-shirt in
the jacket
[Music]
we asked you to fix [ __ ]
so thick [ __ ]
i love one black man's opinion don't you
on my feed and i i jumped on that i'm
like he nailed every piece of that
and absolutely of course you we we know
that he was talking about uh back in
june when yeah juneteenth right and he
was 100 right about that
well i think i think that was a lot of
the narrative not that it was bad that
they did it it just like they wanted
this big pat on the back like you know
they had done something great and of
course uh i think i think a lot of the
hype was that the right wing was like oh
it's not a holiday and you know you know
how it goes back and forth like that oh
yeah but
if you noticed he had a certain kind of
hat on and i don't know and this is
where tony comes in there were three
creators in that video that's right i
don't know if the easter egg was obvious
there or not but but that's how i cuz i
sent uh i sent michael a hat for being
on the show
and uh as as a thank you for i think
he's been on two two episodes i believe
i think so i had to go back and and
double check i'm on episode this is
going to be episode 47
nice i think i don't know but anyways uh
michael jay has been on a couple
episodes so i sent him a hat
and uh
and he was wearing the hat and he must
he must have been channeling the [ __ ] um
and why he was doing that yeah i don't
know if there's like this [ __ ] power
that comes with the head or not but
so i want to know you you wear a certain
head and you got it on right now so tell
us what that hat means okay so people
that don't know me people that know me
know where this originated when i first
started tick tock
i made some political videos and
the comments on
on my pages like on these videos were so
crazy and so mean
it was like i just had to laugh and i
thought you know what i'm gonna come up
with a series called what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you comments that make you
think what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
and then i went through
a couple of different comments in this
ridiculous voice
and um i would just like roast these
people and people fell in love with
these videos because they were so kind
of they were funny and i was roasting
people and it was just it was great so
you know everyone my hashtag before my
my tic toc page was banned i had the
hashtag had like
i don't know it was like 10 million
views or something like this particular
hashtag it had all of my my videos
attached to it
um so that's where that originated from
but the more videos that i did where i
was roasting people the less shitty
comments i was getting i was like come
on people
and then i
put it so it kind of like it kind of
played against itself there yeah yeah so
so i would put another like video out
there to piss them off so they would
leave shitty comments and or people
would stitch me
and then i would take that stitch and i
would just rip them to shreds and it was
just it was so much fun but then tic toc
started censoring me and taking them
down and hitting me with temporary bands
and all this other happy horse [ __ ] so i
actually had stopped making them for a
while so i i think we actually have one
here uh yeah this was from oh my gosh
oh when was this summer of
i don't even know it was like summer of
2020 okay so it's during like quarantine
and that's what it was like august or
something because they could get pretty
brutal on tick tock they're pretty
brutal on twitter too but but people can
get pretty brutal on tic tac and i know
i know uh
like the tick tock
board thing isn't quite as sophisticated
as like twitter or something um it's
it's very simple which makes it to where
like spelling errors or just like
running rampant and of course
when you when you have like q anon maga
oh god trump bumpers out there trying to
type in a comment
um and not not only not only does spell
check not work very well in the tick
tock the sentence structure [ __ ]
if if sentence structure exists at all
really i mean a lot of times i would get
like comments and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are they saying like
i have no idea what i i know you're
against me i can tell that but i can't
tell why or what the argument is but but
i do have one of these videos of the
comments let me play that real quick and
you can tell us more about it
hello and welcome to comments that make
you think what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you part 30
yeah we're 30.
let's take a look at our first shitty
ass comment
i'm betting you don't know where your
meds are please find them
let me see let me see what i can find in
here
oh
well there's nothing in here for me in
terms of medicine but i do have
something for you
now piss off you hateful son of a [ __ ]
let's take a look at our second
comment you make me want to stick two
knives in my ears
oh
i'm sorry
am i supposed to stop you
carry on
oh man
so that was fun that one went viral
did it did it so so um let's talk about
your is speaking of viral and tick tock
because you had an account that had over
yeah like 618 i had gotten up to 626 and
then they just started they they they
shadow ban you and then they start
taking followers away from you right and
then they perma banned it and then they
permit yeah i had so many temporary
back-to-back temporary bands i had like
five four-day temporary bands and then a
seven day right at the end of that and
then i just left it alone for a while
came back made a video and they
perma-banned me
wow well and and i that that's one
reason why i i hadn't made as many tick
tock videos
in the last several months because it
got to where
not only would they not like
you know
show my videos or show my content
because i think like i i i
my preference was not to do like the
reply videos or the stitches or duets i
didn't do a lot of that i would just
make my video and post my video i had my
my walking [ __ ] rant and then i had
my have you ever noticed that was kind
of my my two formats that i did that i
post on tick tock and um
and that you know i get i get views but
not as many as i used to because i don't
think i was doing the thing that that
the tick tock algorithm or you know the
tick tock gods as it were
wanted me to do yeah so i kind of laid
back and i posted like clips of my
podcast and stuff um for people on tick
tock to know that hey i'm still out here
i'm still doing stuff if you want to
listen but i wasn't making as many uh
quote-unquote tick-tocks and i i think
it's because
you know there's there's all different
sides of tick-tock and the political
side of tick tock gets really nasty with
bands and everything because you because
you piss off one person did you ever do
tick-tock lives at all like yeah i did i
did do i never got i never got shut off
alive like i never got shut down on a
live but i i rarely did lives like
i loved when they when they added the
duet
aspect of the lives so i could actually
be on with someone because it just felt
so weird to be on there
like talking to
people that i you know like just
answering comments and stuff i really
like the interaction with another person
so um but i it was rare that i went live
um on tick tock
but
well you know that that is uh because i
would go on lives and the uh i actually
like talking to no one but someone
because i like i as my audience knows
i'll talk and do the microphone to
myself for like an hour
like an hour two hours you know you guys
have seen the twitch stream where i i go
on and i i surf twitter uh we're calling
it the shitlist roundup now um so the
[ __ ] list roundup and of course the
podcast is usually an hour of me ranting
but soon that may change soon that may
change we're gonna change some formats
and then we have the special guest
episodes yeah and speaking of podcast
the guest i have on today has a podcast
i do so what can you show so what is the
nicki news show tell us about the nikki
news show and how that works okay so the
birth of the nicki news show all started
where i wanted to take um
some of my content and extend it
because at time you could only
only pull on tick tock you didn't have
that three minute option
so um people were like we want more we
want do a podcast do a you know whatever
so i was like all right so i would start
making it was the nikki welcome to the
nicki new show and um i would
i would pre-record and i would have my
little you know four sometimes up to
eight minute um nicki new news um and
then i would have guests on um so that
would be live and that would be anywhere
from like
45 minutes to an hour and 15 or whatever
and i would just ask them questions we'd
play games it was fun
it was kind of like a plethora of things
that i was kind of trying out um
and then i you know i post some of my
videos on there on the youtube channel
um i sent a bunch of people over when my
account was getting attacked on tick
tock so i've got like 15
hundred followers over there are um
subscribers i guess you i guess you will
if you will
um and i haven't been doing much over
there lately i've kind of been taking
ever since my big account on tick tock
has been banned um i've kind of pulled
back a little bit um for my mental
health
it's really not healthy sometimes to go
at it hardcore all the time all day
every day and you just kind of need a
break and i'm in that i think i'm in
that moment right now where i'm just
taking a breather
um and then i'll get back to it i i feel
you social media can really uh
especially that's why i don't go over on
uh the instagrams and i want you to
school me on the instagrams like i was
talking about earlier because uh i don't
really i have an instagram account i
have a facebook account but i don't work
over there a lot because uh i like the
tweety tweets you know that that's my
favorite is twitter uh i'll admit it
i'll admit it out there i'm a twitter
fan
jack eat your heart out but but um but
it just that's kind of my preference
that's how i like to interact and engage
because sometimes i just like to type
something out i don't want to make a
video right yeah yeah and sometimes i
don't have a picture to show you so i
just i just want to type something um so
that's probably why i like twitter yeah
but school me on the instagrams because
i was
is it a gram do you regret do you share
what is what is that what what happened
so i mean you have okay so the great
thing about instagram where you don't
what you can't do on tick tock is you
can post a picture and then you can
write in the in the description you can
write whatever you want so it kind of
describes what picture you're posting
you can you can post multiple pictures
um you can post a video and then do the
script descriptions as well you can post
a story where you know somebody can go
up to your little icon and you know
click on it and it would be
a story that you put on there you can
put music to it you can put you can do
all these little effects to it and it's
kind of like a 15 second hitter so was
it like like kind of like a miniature
tic toc because i noticed you know
youtube's doing their shorts
well yeah they do have reels they have
reels on
i think it's reels it's reels on
instagram and shorts on on youtube yeah
because they're they're trying that kind
of platform because i think that they
know that tick tock has had a lot of
issues with you know what's going on
with their platform
and they're seeing how oh god how
effective these these quick hitters are
right well they see the demand right
they see the demand that the creators
want to make these short videos because
i think i think um i think that was the
thing that interests me about tick tock
because i opened my tick tock account i
think i think it was um
before
coronavirus happened but i really
started to get active like when the
quarantine like i was like you know i
took the handle and then when quarantine
happened i picked it up and i did the
stupid dance videos you can actually
they're still on there they're still on
there you can go look you just gotta
scroll way down but i did that and then
um um
and i did a lot of stupid you know we
all did right tony right i got i got
some embarrassing maybe i should go
delete them now because now everyone's
gonna go and try to find these damn
things and they'll be posting them
everywhere um but but um
but then one day i was pissed off after
the election and i did i walked every
day up and down my street so i just
opened up tick-tock and i started
yelling and screaming into the phone
and i post it and everyone's like yeah
we love it and i'm like what the hell so
then i started doing more and more and
more and that's and that's kind of how
it led up to this
um but i haven't got on the instagrams
out there and now that i know you can
post videos and pictures you know i i
kind of done instagram before but not
really been over there now now
everyone's going to want me to start
posting more and more stuff well here's
the thing it's like when i started on
twitter i'm like what the hell because
it's so different from tiktok right like
i didn't know what the heck i was doing
i'm like why i just put this out but why
i couldn't understand it so i am slowly
learning that and i like it better now
that i know more about it right and
that's where you are with instagram so
right the more correct you investigate
and you work at it the more you'll enjoy
it because
you know you'll start to see
people starting to follow you now i i'm
kind of at a standstill on instagram i
i'm i've been sitting it
uh i think i'm at 20
700 or something i i'm completely
stagnant over there right now and i
don't know if instagram is just not
putting me into their algorithm because
i did get hit with two violations one
was appealed and was fine the other one
wasn't you criminal
yes i know i'm horrible but like
organically it doesn't seem to be moving
like um
well i think that happens a lot with
social media like as as you're you know
rather you're content creators like we
are or you're a commenter which a lot of
people are commenters yeah um you know
and a lot of people uh
they like to take other people's uh
content and then comment on it and share
it um like you know sometimes they put
their spin on what that content is so
like all those people inside social
media
rather rather be like a cat video or
political videos like ours um you know
all that stuff's
you know fun but the thing that i like
the best
the thing that i love and most people
like oh i hate nope nope i love the
manga trolls i love them
oh i love them so much
it it it it makes me feel so warm inside
and it makes me know that i'm right on
the right track getting a reaction
that's well i'm on the right track when
the wrong people are pissed off at me
you know when they're when when the
manga trump pumping trolls
are pissed off at me and they feel such
a need to
not just one comment but like two
comments and man they're just they're
pounding it and they follow me for like
days and they'll actually follow me on
twitter and then everything i post like
they're put in a comment i'm like oh
thank you so much i love you for
boosting my content
i thank you for being and it makes me
feel great inside when you're you're a
racist homophobic and i can tell from
your profile and you hate my stuff like
this is fantastic i know i'm on the
right track of
of what we're supposed to be doing here
yes to make a change because do you
think you think social media because i'm
going to play a clip of of uh a tick
tock that you did is kind of like you
you did a video someone clap back at you
so that you clap back at them and i want
you to tell us how that works yeah yeah
um but do you think social media with
like tick tock
and twitter instagram or any of these
social media platforms rather be
facebook or um snapchat or
really any of them do you think it
really do you think we're moving the
needle at all
yeah i'm so glad you asked this question
because i had this conversation with my
husband and a reason why i've kind of
pulled back from social media is because
when i'm thinking about it i am very
opinionated anybody that knows me or
follows me i'm very very opinionated um
which is also
what's the word i'm looking for it's
i i have a lot of critical thinking in
the things that i put out
um a lot of logic
but i'll put something out and i i will
elicit
um a reaction from the other side and it
will piss them off the things that i put
so i think to myself the people that
follow me and they are on my side they
understand where i'm coming from they're
always going to be on my side they're
always going to agree with me
am i actually
am i ever going to get these people that
are against me to agree with me am i
just dividing i sometimes i think to
myself in the content that i put out am
i just dividing the country further or
am i making a difference that's
something that i struggle with on a
daily basis when i make content
so so when you're making content are you
are you thinking about these things like
okay is this is this video or whatever
it is picture tweet uh instagram post is
this is this is this going to convince
someone of what i think or is it just
hey i'm i'm giving my opinion so
you know or
you know so are you thinking about those
things and doing like this strategic
thing are you just you make something
you're like oh
that's too much or a little bit of both
you think like sometimes i react and i
make something in the heat of the moment
and then other times i'll be um
thoughtful about what i want to say and
i'll i'll have that in the equation
about okay is this going to
convince anyone and i think i was more
um democratic about it or like
diplomatic about
um the things that i would post prior to
the 2020 election right because i had
like i would just try and convince
people do not vote for trump i'm telling
you like this guy is a wannabe dictator
so i would make stuff i had several
people reach out to me via dm
um direct message saying you i've been
watching you for a few months you
changed my mind i wasn't even gonna vote
and now i voted for biden because you
made things so clear
that to me was worth every single second
and and you know
like just poured myself into my work
that made
that made it all like
so so you actually feel felt like you
moved i felt like i made a difference
prior to the election and the onset of
the election
and it slowly kind of i feel like pulled
away because yeah you know what we won
we we got we got him out so maybe people
maybe like
not not necessarily audiences or
followings but some
some people on social media have gotten
maybe not complicit but just kind of
moved on like like the rest of the
country's like you [ __ ] lost it's
time to move on those people are moving
on is that what you think it is or i
think so many people including myself
have political fatigue right it has we
thought that things would simmer down
after trump lost in november of 2020.
and in fact that that's not what
happened at all i mean we saw it kind of
him trying to take power
from the moment he lost to you know
still still trying i mean it's obviously
dwindled out but um
just trying to take power and it was it
was so incredibly
um stressful because there was no lull
there was no relief there was no it just
kept on going and these people the
misinformation that was thrown out there
is devastating to our
to our democracy and um and it's
continuing still and these people if it
were just a few fringe people that
believed in this stuff that would be one
thing but that's not the case there are
millions of people that have bought into
this horseshit
and um you know i think people are just
tired i'm gonna round back around where
i started people are just tired my
husband told me the other day and he's a
democrat right he is very smart he
follows politics he's just like i'm
[ __ ] done man like i am exhausted
right [ __ ] like it's just the same thing
do you think do you think that's what
they're counting on because i i know
we're going to take a break here in a
minute because i want to play this video
the clap back and talk about that yeah
we're going to take a break here in a
minute but um and when we come back i
want to play a video that you did about
the january 6 uh committee and i think i
think that's where a lot of americans
are pissed off because they just some of
that stuff which we see the rolling
stones article um that just came out
yesterday and we'll talk about that too
after the break uh relating to the
january 6th select committee but because
that's real news and that is moving
needles uh not just uh in the public but
like real needles like
what getting to the bottom of what
happened because i think that's what
americans are really sick of and the
fatigue
is that we're not getting to the bottom
of what what happened and not only that
is that really
trump and trump allies and and maga and
really q anon
and all these election fraud nut jobs
they're counting on us to have fatigue
they're counting on it that's why they
keep doing it
you see it no more clear than uh sb8 in
texas where the pro-lifers said you know
what we're throwing up our hands we
don't care about the about dancing
around a woman's life or rape or incest
anymore we're just gonna go full on in
and we're gonna we're gonna make them
the pro-lifers
the gqp the the the wackadoos in the
party just went straight after and said
i mean they've had this plan for decades
with sba they never they never tried it
um because they thought it they thought
that they would actually turn women
against them i believe this strategy
that they're doing turns women who would
have some pro-life um views and be
possibly on that side this law
absolutely they go what the [ __ ]
a bounty how is it i mean you know
so i think
they're all in and they're gonna go all
in and they're gonna be all in for the
next two years at least this and and so
political fatigue or not
that's where i think the country's
getting tired is with like the january 6
select committee the steve bannon guard
well no one's being accountable right
well there seems to be two separate sets
of rules right yes there are do as i say
not as i do but
we can get away with this you see the
people that were
like actually being held accountable the
people that were there in january 6 the
the the
the civilians that went in and you know
they're they're starting to be held
accountable and getting sentenced and
you know all of that stuff but the
people the catalysts the people that
cultivated this the people that were
behind the scenes
still have not been held accountable and
that's where january 6th the january 6th
commission i hope to god this is the
last chance to hold any of these people
accountable we're going to talk about it
let me play the video that i have of a
clapback speaking of of crazy wackadoos
this person this video obviously is
getting history and facts all twisted
and turned around and you kind of try to
set the record straight so let me play
that we'll talk about that and then
we'll go to a break okay people do that
people can't well name the one group
that could literally
go to college based only off the color
of your skin oh i know this one it's
white people name the one group that
could have any form of business that
they wanted and say that it was
exclusive only to that certain color
waiting room for whites only whites only
we want white tenants in our white
community we watch for white people only
trump nation whites only
make america white again
uh
it's white people again that could
literally get alone by souling off of
their skin and nothing else disparity in
home lending cost minorities millions
black home buyers denied mortgages more
than twice as often as whites why it
costs more to borrow if you're black
you were saying
that's right
black
[Music]
black people
are not discriminated against lifetime
risk of being killed by police black
versus white
the history of police brutality against
black people in america black unarmed
victims of police brutality
you thought you did something there
didn't you from where i'm sitting it
looks like you're not very happy with
your life and you're trying to blame
somebody for it
so we could probably do three hours on
uh a podcast of commenting on what she's
saying how she's saying it but the
ultimate uh thing that i i i want you to
break down for the audience exactly what
this is this back and forth on tick tock
this stitch but i also
i think that the misinformation that
this person has either been fed their
entire lives or just now starting to eat
on social media and what i mean by that
is there's a steady diet for anyone out
there who has uh is predisposed to this
type of thinking um to
basically be programmed of all that
and msnbc did a documentary in a civil
board last night i guess they released
it i haven't watched it yet i want to
watch it but i don't have cable so i
have to go to like my mom's house and
eat off her and you know
mooch off her but but
my point here is is that um
the misinformation like you were saying
earlier and how it has given the people
without misinformation like your husband
like you know
how it's giving them fatigue
and it's the intention
is for it to give fatigue yeah for you
to get so tired to go whatever just
whatever you want to think whatever you
want to believe right right and we'll
just we'll move on and you people can
have what you want and i think i think
that is their plan so knowing that
that's their plan uh anyone out there
listening
know that that's their plan and you
should take breaks from social media
especially when your brain hurts
[Laughter]
when your brain hurts but tell us about
um not the video and the subject itself
but tell us what that is as far as
social media is concerned where you are
talking back and forth to this person
tell us
first and foremost i want to just kind
of add to what you said
um
regardless of social media we need to
get out and we need to vote we need to
vote on a local level state level we
need to vote go [ __ ] vote we have to
vote your vote matters together
you know we can make a difference just
remember that your vote is very
important um democrats in the past have
gotten complacent we can't be complacent
anymore okay so i will talk about the
stitch so i would get somebody that
would take one of my videos and stitch
it and then have their own commentary
put on there
then i what i would do is i would save
the video and i would edit it and i
would put my own commentary in between
each one of the things that they would
say
and i've done that several times i've
just shredded people because the the
like you know the misinformation the
playing the victim card you know like it
it's ridiculous some of these things
that i i had gotten and it's a choice a
couple choice ones i did
like that one deal hugely reposted on um
instagram it's called the repost just so
you know so
i'll repost oh okay
well i didn't know if it was a grammy
gram or a regram or
so so
a teddy graham or a graham cracker i
don't know
so let me let me ask you about uh
let me let me ask you about the the
stitch because a lot of my uh listeners
aren't on tick tock so the stitch and
what you're doing there is kind of like
a debate where you guys are using the
two videos and debating back and forth
right like like they might do in a
comment thread on on twitter where
you're just debating back and forth
where she made you made a video she
responded to your video yeah and then
you responded back to her videos so
you're kind of so that's what the
stitches and duets are on tick tock is
the trying to debate back and forth
through this this video platform right
as opposed to typing out everything um
and arguing back and but here's here's
the thing about those stitches it's rare
that i stitch anybody right i always
responded to people that did a stitch
for me the thing about a stitch is it
will take literally a five second you're
only allowed like if you actually use
the stitch
so is that why you pull the video and
cut it is that what you know like let's
say let's say one of my videos is
playing go oh i want to stitch that if
it has the option you hit stitch and you
can go to any part of the video and
stitch five seconds it'll take a five
second um snippet from my video
and then you can add whatever you want
right to the end of it right so
your commentary right but here's the
thing is that
this is where i have like have so much
more empathy toward people
that get things taken out of context
because somebody would take a stitch and
take five seconds of a 60 second video
that i did and completely take it out of
context right they make it sound like
i'm talking about something completely
different but if you watch the whole
video you get the entire context right
right so the stitch actually
encourages people to be able to take
things out of context and then that's
when i'm like no
it's this you know i'd correct them
or i just you know go after them because
they're idiots but [ __ ] them you [ __ ]
them welcome that's it i gotta get you
to say [ __ ] them a couple times on the
show we'll cut it up and we'll make
we'll make it to where nicki news says
[ __ ] him a lot um
so so um one thing i i i uh want to say
bef before we go to a break about the uh
the stitch back and forth and all that
um and the out of context because it
reminds me
way back when it seems like a million
years ago when we had a president that
no one liked
you know because he was a black dude we
all know that's the reason why yeah and
he said something somewhere i think it
was in arizona he said you got a
business
you didn't build that you remember that
and they they took it they took
completely mitt romney
we built that or something i mean it was
at the rnc and the their national
committee it was crazy how they took
that one little snippet yeah blasted it
all over right wing uh media and all of
a sudden that became the thing so well i
don't think that's i don't think that
that is just characteristic of the right
side it's characteristic of both sides
sure and like they've been doing that to
fit they've been taking snippets like
that on both sides to fit their
narrative and it's just how they play
ball look at nikki punching both ways
good for you nick yeah i mean hold them
accountable and let's let's do this
let's go to a break and then we'll talk
about holding people accountable when we
get back don't stay right with us stay
right with us
[Music]
find us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
and at the tonymichaels or be lame and
don't [ __ ] boneheads
we'll be back in 60 seconds
[Music]
[ __ ] spread
and that's why that's why he's getting
his shows canceled ain't because travis
tritt wants to cancel him
think about this think about the phone
call
travis calls up to the venue the venue's
like hey travis we can't let anyone in
that's not vaccine and he's like what do
you mean well he can't let anyone in
that's not vaccinated he says well me
and my entire band aren't vaccinated
they're like
you can't come in our building
well how the hell is travis tripp going
to do a [ __ ] country music show if
him and his entire [ __ ] band can't
enter the [ __ ] building think about
it travis tritt isn't canceling shows
he's getting cancelled by the [ __ ]
venues who are like nah
no no one can come in you can't come in
without a vaccine passport you or anyone
else dumb [ __ ]
that travis tritt isn't canceling shows
he's getting his shows cancelled cause
he's a [ __ ] bonehead
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back thanks for staying
with us you know our special guest today
is nikki new you can find her on the
socials
at
nikki new 813 it's n-i-k-i-n-o-o-813
you can find her
on all those socials
on the socials
welcome back welcome back nikki so tell
us about your socials and then we'll get
to the january 6th because i know i know
because your permabanned on um
on the uh on the tiki talks it is it is
kind of touch and go over there you're
still nicking new eight one three um
nikki knew eight one three eight one
three thousand okay so we just add we
just add an additional eight one yeah
but i think i added i should have done
2.0 but
uh well i think because your name is
nikki new
813 it pulls you up it pops up when you
search so it's n-i-k-k-i-n-o-o-813
on the on the on the graham crackers the
tweety tweets but on tick-tock
and on youtube oh youtube is the nikki
new show the nikki news show and i think
so i think you're you're in there i
think i searched on there to make sure
it would pull up the eight one i think
it pulls up the 813 i think if you do
put uh youtube nikki new 813 it pulls me
up yeah yeah i think i think so i think
so
so um let's talk about this you've seen
uh
when we came on before we came on the
show we were talking about this rolling
stone article and i was reading through
it this morning because i i read
snippets of it last night and i i
tweeted about it
um it's nothing that we don't already
assume right because we've watched this
whole thing play out for
[ __ ] almost 10 months now so we know
the people that are acting crazy in the
public sphere and on social media like
your marjorie taylor greens your your
paul gozar's your lauren boberts uh mo
brooks some of these other
chuckleheads right um they've been
acting crazy about january 6th and oh it
was just a tourism thing and oh you know
it they keep going on and on and
changing the story it was antifa then it
was black lives matter then then they
were great patriots who were just on a
tour of the capitol i mean it just
constantly they're moving the goal post
and again they're trying to give us
fatigue here i believe is what's
happening they didn't want to have the
911 style commission now we're at the
point where we have the january select
committee in the house
which is led by benny thompson the
democrat and then the co-chair is liz
cheney republican which we could talk
about that a whole time but
we we did see some movement with steve
bannon and getting voted in criminal
contempt in the house we'll see what the
doj does we'll talk about that maybe for
a little bit
but this rolling stone article but
before we do that i want to show a video
that you did
um on the january 6
committee so let's show that and then
we'll talk about this stuff on the other
side this is to all the trump supporters
out there that tried to use the
constitution to defend the january sixth
insurrection pay attention you might
learn something all of our oaths here
today
to protect and defend the constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
will be our guiding light for this
investigation enemies foreign and
domestic domestic being the people that
stormed the capital that day and the
people that incited it you see the
january 6 insurrection is exactly why
the constitution was written this way
and if you're one of those people that
believe that the january 6 commission is
a witch hunt you're either too stupid to
realize what's going on or you're a
fascist i said what i said
that was that was another repost by dl
oh so dll you see yeah is a huge fan
yeah and nikki knew apparently he's he's
he's like all over your pages yeah but
he never he never tags me oh he doesn't
post my [ __ ] do you hear that deal if
you're out there dl start tagging
me please come on come on when you're
doing that when you're doing the reaper
stuff again
when you're doing the re-graham cracker
and whatever it is yeah the graham
cracker you know go ahead and
tag nicki new in it and while you're at
it dl give me a follow back on instagram
yeah there you go there you go also the
the the follow back yeah so if dl's
listening we'll get him to do that um so
back the the january 6 because you make
a lot of good points in that video and
that this crescendo that's happening
with uh
the january 6th select committee i think
um kind of
elevated last last night with this
rolling stone article and what this
rolling stone article is alleging is
that there are there are a couple people
uh two of them in particular and it
seems like they have been given immunity
from the january sixth select committee
for their testimony not just about
january 6 and their participation and
but the ultimate thing here is who
helped organize it and there's possibly
a list a list
of congress people which i think is
probably the most important thing about
the steve bannon thing uh no one has
connected this i'm gonna go on twitter
and blast us out later i think this is
the connection uh with steve ben and i
think that's why steve bannon is doing
what he's doing and i'll tell you about
that here in a second but let's look at
a a little snippet from the rolling
stone article
along with green and they're talking
about marjorie taylor green here
other top staffers have been having
conversations with reps including paul
gozar from arizona he's the jack jaw
guide it looks like he's on uh drugs uh
lauren bobert you know uh pew pew lauren
bobert uh mo brooks yeah madison cothorn
which i won't even go there no andy
biggs and then louie uh
i lose teeth gohmert so
this um but but down at the bottom this
is a quote from one of the organizers
and one of the organizers is one of the
people
that is talking to the january 6
select committee there's an organizer
and a planner is how they put it in this
article and then there's also maybe a
third person that hasn't gotten immunity
yet but is also cooperating
but the organizer says we would talk to
bobert's team cawthorne's team goes arts
team like back to back to back i think
that is very
very significant when we're talking
about planning
for the uh january 6th but also in this
article it goes on to talk about how
they would use white house liaisons to
communicate with the president
and the reason why that's significant
nikki is because this next snippet it
says uh goes-r paul gosar of arizona you
know the jack-jawed um um freak at the
guy
if you've ever seen him do like a
interview you're like what what kind of
stuff are you on she's louise that's for
everyone that's listed here oh my god
but but he says of course it says he's
one of the most prominent defenders of
the rioters which i wouldn't call them
rioters i would call them
that's right they're insurrectionist
um but he took it a step forward where
he would actually
in these meetings he would he would
dangle this is their words dangle the
possibility of blank blanket pardons
so in other words like
all the all the all the insurrections
all the rioters as this article puts
puts it that would commit federal crimes
by
doing an insurrection and trying to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states by trying to [ __ ] all over our
government all over our democracy that
somehow
goes-r would set up a situation where
maybe someone like the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
would do a blanket pardon so all these
people who were taking a tour of the
capitol um would need pardons if you
nikki let me ask you
have you ever been to um
washington yes okay so when you took a
tour you probably took it i did i didn't
end up taking a tour i went with my
husband and we we just went for like a
day we just walked around we did right
but but if you were going to take a tour
would you think that you would need to
make sure to set up a pardon for that
tour
um with the president united states and
events probably not probably not so that
is where this intent comes in with this
article and i believe this is where the
steve bannon connection is
because the one thing that the cheeto
dust monster grandpa poopy pants
does
for sure a hundred percent and we know
it
is that he thinks
he is in the lacoster nostra right he's
he's he's a mob boss he thinks he's
untouchable that's right so he doesn't
talk to people he has people go talk and
then they come report that way he can
say like i've never say anything i've
never met i only take pic i take
pictures with a lot of people yeah so
so tell me about what your thoughts are
with these representatives
being possibly involved in this and
what not what that means like
um
for them because obviously if there's
criminal uh charges that are being
brought uh i think a lot of people are
calling for expulsion of congress which
i think is a very quick step at a
minimum but where do you think this goes
as far as the landscape uh well there's
a timeline right um if you think about
it all really kind of started in 2016
when trump started with the whole
undermining our elections and saying
that if he loses it's because the dems
cheated
right so he wins and then it just kind
of all goes away but then you know he
starts as soon as you know 2020
elections coming up he is in there just
you know saying that the elections are
you know
if he loses he's starting this whole
rhetoric again so he's putting this into
the mind of his his supporters okay so
this is already in their minds like if
he loses there's no way this guy's gonna
lose because if he loses if the
democrats cheated
he set this this this he has been
planting the seed since 2016.
and um with that knowing like he's a
sore loser obviously he can't admit that
he lost
um
he has he has this base now the people
in congress the people in power
see this huge like 72 million people
that vote or 78 million i don't even
care it was something like that that
voted for this [ __ ] guy right
and um they're looking at this base like
holy cow there's a lot of people we need
to placate to this base so then they
continue this lie after the election
which is uh undoing and completely
undermining our democracy in the you
know so then you have these these people
in power like that are these fringe you
know people q anon conspiracy people
like marjorie taylor green and you know
some of these people that are now being
investigated
saying you know what we can we can
probably just take power if we do it
this way they actually had a plan
this is it's all there i mean it's
always been there i've been saying this
since the get-go okay and then so all
this happens now like bannon or you know
or whoever it was that was dangling
those you know blank and pardons they're
like oh well if this goes to the shutter
we're going to be covered because we're
going to get a blanket pardon
so you know it's not going to affect us
but if it does go our way then all of a
sudden we're back in power now you know
whatever they're thinking because it's
crazy right
um and then
things go to [ __ ] he gets he's not he
actually leaves the white house he
doesn't give anybody a pardon
and there are no besides like steve
bannon besides steve bannon
right right though those people but
these other people that have that plate
of
this that we know of now they're
flapping like a you know like a fruit in
the where like a fish and out of water
right like oh my god so now they're
saying all this stuff because they know
how malleable his base is and how how
they're like easily manipulated they are
and they they're telling them what these
people want to hear and so now it's like
well this isn't true this these people
are heroes no you know so people are
buying into that and now all this stuff
is coming to fruition where
um you know they they did have meetings
they were trying to you know destroy our
democracy and overturn you know and take
the power
and um i think really honestly their
their world is crumbling right now and
i hope to god that the floor falls out
from under them and everything is
exposed because then these these
supporters
will hopefully see it for what it is do
you think do you think that's the case
do you think they'll really domestic
terrorists no
i mean i mean i mean they want to
believe it's i i've said this uh you
know over and over and over again we are
at the intersection of wrestlemania and
real life these people actually know
this is all horseshit it's all [ __ ]
just like a wrestling match not not
anything against wrestling they want
their side to win no matter right they
and they want to pretend that it's real
i think that's a lot of it right now
back to the steve bannon because i think
you make a good point on the pardons and
bannon and who's involved because i
actually think the reason why steve
bannon is is uh
being held in contempt because he's not
participating with the subpoena he's
he's unlawfully uh rejecting the
subpoena here and i think he should be
jailed very quickly but
but i think that steve bannon was the
go-between for this group of people um
because steve bannon
has marjorie taylor green on his podcast
a lot so they have to communicate to
some level and have been communicating
for a long time uh and that is one of
the people inside this group of people
that was communicating along with goes-r
so surely
this is where
the communication between trump which
they're claiming executive privilege
which if really if really trump is
claiming if trump is claiming not bannon
but he's not president well but if trump
but if trump is claiming executive proof
which i don't think he has but if he's
claiming executive privilege what he's
saying is he's saying
he's saying that he had communication
with steve bannon like you're admitting
it out in the open
it's all there if people want to see
it's all right here in front of us they
just refuse to see it they we need
that's right they we they need
it's all there it's all right there if
they choose to see it and they don't and
it's because exactly what you said
because they're on the other side of it
and they're like well if i admit i'm
wrong you know so many people in this
country will never admit that they're
wrong again no matter the cost and you
think do you think that's because
do you think that's because it's not
like a win-lose thing it's just like
well if i'm wrong about this then
everything else falls apart i think it's
both kind of i think i think it's a
pride thing and i think it's a it'll
blow their their com all of their
beliefs about what they have stood so
hard for a way this [ __ ] about like crt
critical race theory yeah that's a whole
mask and anti-vex but but it's all but
isn't it all one issue nikki don't you
think it's all kind of one
this this whole i mean i know they're
separate issues but it's all this one
crux of
we want we want what we want and we're
going to get it no matter what and we're
entitled to it because we get to do
whatever we want we get to go to the
capitol and overthrow the constitution
united states because we want our guy to
win we get to pretend like there was all
kinds of crap with the voting that's
right
i i think yeah i think
i think it's white privilege but i mean
it is and i think there are several
things that play into this so many
several things okay
um but here's here's the biggest problem
that we have right now is you have the
right side you have the left side
anything the right says the left is like
nope nope nope nope the right said it
it's not true right a lot of times it's
not and the same thing with the right
the right is like oh well the left said
it so it's not true they automatically
just they they they they throw it away
the notion because it came from whatever
side and that's the problem that we have
is that even if the right said something
that was true the left is like [ __ ] them
you can't believe anything they say and
the right says that about the left
because let's face it you can go out
onto social media and find anything to
support the way you
view things oh yeah there's going to be
someone out there that is going to have
your viewpoint on the subject that you
want that you're interested on right at
this moment you'll find it and not only
will you find it the algorithm will feed
it to you like here you go baby scary
part is that things like places like
facebook and it has been proven time and
time again that they they dump stuff
into your feed to keep those
conspiracies like if you're if you
search q and they're they're gonna keep
throwing stuff at you because they know
it's something that you're interested in
and then you fall down this rabbit hole
and the next thing you know you're like
where am i you know you know
i'll tell you i'll tell you a couple
different things here because i think i
think we're on to something here uh
we don't need to get complacent go
[ __ ] vote i actually uh put a graphic
up on twitter
stay pissed um it was it was it was
someone commented something in uh
something that i posted and i got mad so
i decided to instead of clapping back i
made a little graphic and it said stay
pissed hashtag go [ __ ] vote and i
think that's that's the main key here is
that uh you know take your breaks where
you need to
um from this whole political thing but
stay pissed stay pissed not just stay
pissed at uh
the manga the trump bumpers but stay
pissed at democrats you know we we still
have this infrastructure built there's a
lot of things going on to distract these
politics and their their idea is to have
a chaos machine and to make us uh like
you said have exhaustion you know to be
to be completely exhausted from it that
we disengage which we don't need to
disengage uh because we definitely have
to vote the next vote is virginia so go
if you're in virginia go [ __ ] vote um
go vote in your local elections that's
right that's the only way the level
people don't realize how incredibly
important that is because while you know
we're over here we're distracted over
here they're making all this legislation
in the states and and and um restricting
voting like you bills there that are
being put out and put into law and you
know the next thing we know 2022 is
going to come around i i i'm telling you
right now if people do not get out and
vote in 2022 and we lose the house and
the senate we are [ __ ] because across
the board they are going to change
legislation for they're going to
restructure everything and they're going
to make it extremely difficult for us to
ever get those seats again and i i mean
which sets up a possible trump
or somebody like trump in 2024 to take
the president oh god i hope there's no
one out there that's exactly like trump
there's two of them holy [ __ ] well
here's the here's the scary thing no i
know tony here's the scary thing is that
people that
have his
same beliefs and um his narcissism and
his
just greed but have a brain behind it
well you know i i think that's a good
point i think that's a good point but
also i think that they don't
and by they i i mean this this movement
this misinformation movement they
actually don't need donald trump anymore
and what i mean by that is because
because donald trump is now enshrined in
this stupid image of him that they have
that isn't even close to what the real
donald trump is like they have this they
have this figure you know this dumb
stupid
legendary thing about him that isn't
even close to the truth and they're all
as long as you will you you want to
support trump you always believe that
that's
that
that figure or that that idea of him is
you know you'll believe that [ __ ]
so
i think uh and you've seen this in his
little statements that he's given
because he can't tweet you see this
where he he tells them what they want
it's a it's the tail wagging the dog the
classic tail wagging the dog he's just
saying
out loud what they want him to say
because he wants their attention because
he's losing it i think because they
don't need him anymore they just need
his name they just need pictures of him
they just need the idea of him they
don't actually need him anymore i mean
when you create this whole russian
propaganda thing because i i think
that's where a lot of it comes from but
you create this whole universe around
him
he doesn't need to be in that universe
anymore right like he doesn't he doesn't
actually have to be a part of it i mean
we see it in virginia like he's not
going and and campaigning for for yunkan
but yunkan is being being really branded
well as trump even though he's not there
and the reason why is because
all this stuff is trumpism and anti-mask
anti-backs uh
they don't have that they have the
voters they have they have the support
and right but it's all but it's all
trumpism right they don't need him for
it to be trumpism does that make sense
make america great again is now
something way beyond him and it'll live
past him because eventually someday he
will pass away no one will give a [ __ ]
but yeah hopefully and but but it will
live long past him and
go ahead yeah i i think this is why
some of the the older republicans where
they wouldn't have stood for this
10 years ago they would they would never
have stood for this kind of
um rhetoric and propaganda and stuff
like that and
but because he has the base that he has
and in addition to that is that the
republican party is is so close to
splintering into two separate parties
the republicans and the the you know the
trump looking party and if that happens
they're screwed and they know because
you're taking
one set of votes and splitting them and
then the dems will always win and that's
what they're terrified of number one
um number two is you know they they know
that this base will vote straight
republican and so now they're tapping
into the base and there there's now
they're starting to say the rhetoric and
the propaganda and they're pushing it
because they they they don't care they
ca all they care about is the power that
they have and the position and the money
that they can continue to have and
they'll say and do anything they are
complete puppets to all of it give them
a [ __ ] at the end because of that
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them
so i i i don't want to cut this off
because i can feel the [ __ ] energy
coming from nicki new right now like she
is pissed she is ready to vote she is
ready to pound the social medias with
with all the ideas and the arguments it
takes to move the needle forward to
progress and to make sure we have
equality and equity in this country and
get rid of this stupid trump humping
maga
fascism as she said earlier in her video
so i appreciate nikki joining us today
nikki before we leave i want you one
more time tell us where everyone can
find you because i know everyone now
that they've heard you uh have that
[ __ ] energy tell them tell them where
they can find you on social media and on
the interwebs okay so i post mainly on
instagram um so instagram
um twitter
and uh is uh nikki new
um you can see it down here nikkinew813
um and then if you go to my tic toc if
you want to follow me about my backup
page
sneakynew813813 and then my youtube is
eight
it's
the nikki new show which it says right
down at the bottom there so you guys can
find me there follow me there you know
throw me a dm um say hey
awesome
thank you for coming on the show we have
to have you back because we we have to
continue this conversation that we had
to cut off because i know the audience
here uh loves the energy of stay pissed
and go [ __ ] vote yeah vote that's the
number one thing guys get out and vote
do your best that is how we can change
is to go [ __ ] vote
go [ __ ] vote so thank you nikki for
joining me i really appreciate it we
will have ha we'll have you back anytime
just
just give us a shout so thanks nikki
have a good one awesome thanks tony
all right nikki nikki knew
the tick tocker the the graham cracker i
don't know what it is what are they
grammars
i don't know i don't know i don't know
anything she's going to teach me about
this instagram maybe maybe maybe we'll
do like a master class with nikki new on
how to get on dl hugley's page or
something like that maybe that's maybe
i'll i'll have her teach me so i want to
thank nikki again for coming on go
follow her over on the tiki tax if
you're there
on the instagrams follow her on twitter
again you can find her at uh nikkinew813
it's nikki
n0813 you can find her almost anywhere
go go subscribe to her youtube channel
uh
the nikki news show that's pretty easy
to find her over there too
and thank you nikki for joining us uh
again this episode will air on friday
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern just like guest episodes do
and i appreciate nick she'd come back on
anytime she wants i know you guys liked
her because she did do you guys think
she had a good a good [ __ ] them she had
a good she had a really good [ __ ] and
i think we'll cut that up to make sure
that we get the [ __ ] you know in the
clips so but before i go i want i want
to say one more thing [ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[ __ ]